Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodassa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and fully self-awakened one.
Okay, so this moon, I've chosen these Atalokadama, these eight worldly conditions, concerns, wins, fortunes, vicissitudes.
It's the ups and downs of life.
I mean, that's basically what it is, yeah.
I'll try and take these off, I think.
So this is what the Buddha says.
Gain obsesses the mind and loss obsesses the mind.
Fame obsesses the mind and disrepute obsesses the mind.
Blame obsesses the mind and praise obsesses the mind.
Pleasure obsesses the mind and pain obsesses the mind.
They are attracted to gain and repelled by loss.
They are attracted to fame and repelled by disrepute.
They are attracted to praise and repelled by blame.
They are attracted to pleasure and repelled by pain.
Thus involved with attraction and repulsion, they are not freed from birth, from old age and death, from sorrow, lamentation, pain, dejection and anguish.
They are not freed from suffering, I say.
So that's the eight worldly conditions.
Now, when we look at those conditions, you can see that they all arise out of a notion of a self.
It's me that's blamed.
It's me that's praised, etc., etc.
And when we do that, of course, it just creates mental turbulence.
When this happens at a societal level, then you can see communities being split, as we see these days.
And of course, when it gets to an international level, well, there's always war going on.
So what's it like to be freed of these worldly concerns?
So in the discourse on the greatest blessings, the Buddha has stated how an awakened Arahant, how somebody who's fully liberated is unmoved by one of the eight worldly conditions.
And he describes this as one of the great blessings.
and it says that a mind unshaken by worldly vicissitudes sorrowless stainless and secure this is the greatest blessing and again we can extend that to families and countries and we might just get to a peaceful world so um what i've done is i've just made up questions around these eight
factors just to give some idea of how we can use them just to reflect on the way we are with these fortunes and misfortunes.
So if we take gain, for instance, you know, is to ask ourselves, what am I obsessing about?
You know, what sort of an accumulation am I gathering?
What collections do I have?
You know, wealth, power,
even though it's even though we might not have much wealth at all or indeed hardly any power the point is this this obsession about it control how much energy do we give to it you see um and how much time do we waste brooding and planning over these sorts of things
And then once we can bring a past event to mind as a practice, we can get in touch with that feeling, that craving, that holding on, you know, the cramped grip.
What does that feel like?
And to try and separate that from what you might call just an ordinary wholesome desire.
I mean, we need money, we need friends, et cetera, et cetera.
But there's a way of having that without that obsessiveness.
And then, of course, there's loss.
And everybody feels that.
You might lose your job.
What does that feel like?
If you have lost your job in the past, how did that feel?
The despair, the confusion, the anxiety, panic?
So much depends upon our work, you know, and the wage that we have.
And then there's the self-worth that we have from our work, you know, the sense of status.
But we'll come to that a bit later.
So we have to just ask ourselves, what if I let go of that?
What if I just let go of the obsessiveness and just be more content with what I have?
And by going to a past occasion and investigating it and reflecting on it, it just helps us to be prepared for the next time.
So we're not so shocked when we lose things, lose our work, lose money on the horses and stuff like that.
So the next one is praise.
So again, we look back and we think, well, what have I done or said or I am doing or saying which has an underlying demand for praise, for admiration, for compliments, for appreciation?
I mean, how does that feel?
Is it necessary?
And how does that reflect on ourselves and how we're judging ourselves?
And how we feel embarrassed when we suddenly realise that we've said something or done something just to be praised, just to be admired.
And what would have happened if you hadn't had that intention in that particular case?
And what should the attitude have been?
When it comes to blame, well, nobody likes that.
Nobody likes to be blamed for anything, you know.
And again, to bring up an occasion in the past where we've been blamed and we've been judged and we've been criticized, you know, and just to get to the hurt of that and how we reacted.
And sometimes, of course, we react silently within ourselves.
We spend hours getting our own back in these fantasies, throwing people on fires and chucking them off bridges and things like that.
So it's getting in touch with those feelings and naming them for what they are, you see.
So what is it like to be humiliated?
Instead of hiding that from ourselves, suppressing it because of our pride,
It's to let it up, you see, to let up and just feel it and to know that if I can just allow these things to manifest, they're actually dying out.
They're actually curing.
Right.
And some of these things are very difficult.
You know, the hurt, the humiliation is it really hurts the ego.
I mean, it really punches the self.
And if we're afraid of criticism, does that make us timid?
Yeah.
Does that make us timid?
And then when we have been blamed and it has been our fault, have we been humble enough to accept that, you know, and try and do something about it and not let that rumble on afterwards about self-criticism?
You know, I'm such a fool.
I'm an idiot.
How could I have done that?
See, it's just it's just being able to let go, to let go of something, you know.
And then we have the area of success and failure.
So again, it's much the same thing.
You bring to mind a past occasion when you feel you've been successful, a job well done.
And there's nothing wrong with appropriate congratulations, you know.
But again, it's this business of hanging on to that success.
I've got here just what the Buddha says about somebody who becomes an Arahant.
He says that someone who's an Arahant with their taints, taints are the roots of all our defilements, a craving for pleasure, craving to become, and ignorance, the basic ignorance of self.
And these are the roots from which all these defilements arise.
So he says when those are destroyed,
and has lived the holy life, done what has to be done or had to be done, laid down the burden, reached the goal, destroyed the fetters of becoming, and is completely liberated through final desire.
So you can see, I mean, you know, it's that sense of completion.
What had to be done has been done.
And if you look at your life where you've really sort of completed something, it's done, it's finished, it's gone.
There's a sense of joy about that.
Yeah.
And lay down the burden, you know, the sense of relief of laying down the burden, laying down the burden of being a human being, basically.
And of course, the taste of Nibbana is the joy of freedom.
Right.
So that's that's where we're heading.
It's good to remind ourselves about that.
And then, of course, when when we are praised, we tend to personalize things.
So immediately it's not it's not the job that's being praised.
It's me.
Right.
I'm amazing.
I get very big headed.
And sometimes, you know, if you catch yourself like that, if you catch yourself being big headed, you know, and full of self praise and all that, then again becomes a sort of and you sort of notice that other people are seeing it as big headedness.
And of course, that again produces a sense of shame within us.
So all these things, you see, just recognize all the ego stuff as unnecessary evaluation tags.
Just let them fade away.
And eventually, as the Buddha said, they just fall off.
uh failure oh that's the next one failure so a job didn't turn out well a relationship sadly ended how's it feel you know not to achieve something uh even if you've put a lot of work into it and it just hasn't happened you know so again you get this personalization the job failed therefore i'm a failure yeah the relationship failed so i'm i'm unlovable right
And it's sort of reflecting on that and recognizing that those personalization of things are just not necessary.
They just add suffering to it.
And if it was a genuine mistake or whatever, we can be realistic about it and to make sure that we don't repeat that same mistake.
But then again, of course, circumstances change.
We don't have that total control anymore.
And finally, there's pleasure and pain.
So pleasure, of course, both mental and physical pleasure.
We're always seeking that.
We're always trying to be in that sort of pleasurable state.
But it's a case of, again, not attaching to it, not making it something that is repeatable.
So when we have something joyful, something pleasant, to accept that it's come to an end and there's no need to go any further with it.
and to find out how we experience desire.
So sometimes, for instance, when it comes to food, you don't feel hungry, so you're not attracted so much to the cake.
But sometimes when you are hungry, you can't stop yourself from eating the whole cake.
So there's something about desire which is separate from seeing something that is pleasant.
Right.
There's that movement towards it of wanting, wanting, wanting.
And then to make that distinction between the desire and the action.
So remember, in Buddhist psychology, this is really crucial because when something is a desire, nothing's actually happened.
It's just potential.
But as soon as you decide to let that energy go and produce something, a thought or
speech something that you do there becomes an action and that action goes out into a matrix of relationships on the outside but it's also moves into the inner matrix of our psyche yeah and that's that's what we've been by karma action and so we're trying to make a distinction here between indulgence and enjoyment
And we do that, and the Buddha's always on about this, by restraining ourselves, right?
That's very difficult in our society.
We're not expected to restrain.
In fact, everybody wants us to indulge.
But the act of restraint gets us in touch with the unacceptable level, you might say, from a Dharma point of view of desire, right?
So in other words, nothing's wrong with appetite.
Everything's wrong with greed.
And then finally pain.
So pain can be very difficult, you know.
And I think one of the things we have to be careful of here is that we don't take what pain comes to us as some sort of karmic resolve.
You know, I deserve the pain.
We're not in charge of the body and the body has its own weaknesses.
And sometimes when the pain comes, it's to do with genetics.
It's not to do with the person themselves.
So it's up to us to decide whether this pain is something that I want to work with.
So you're working with it in terms of getting that right relationship with pain of patience.
understanding what pain is at different levels.
You know, at one level, at the basic level of contact, pain is just sensation, right?
It's when it becomes a feeling, when it's acknowledged as a feeling that you get the sense of pain and then you get that reaction of not wanting it.
But if you can't do that sort of investigation and you haven't got the patience for it, then, you know, take an aspirin, do something.
I was just thinking then of the Act of Parliament that we've had, well, it's not completely passed, about assisted dying, you see.
And it's an area which Buddhists have to really think about and where they are personally with that.
And when pain gets to a point which is cannot be assuaged by any of the morphines and all that sort of stuff, then one has to decide for oneself whether, you know, it's a time to put an end to one's life and whatnot.
And there are various degrees of understanding as to what is right and what is wrong.
But ultimately, it's the individual.
It's for them to feel OK with it.
Yeah.
So that's a big topic, that.
So again, going back to the Buddha and just giving him a bit of time to quote there.
Here we go.
So when gain arises for an uninstructed, run-of-the-mill person,
They do not reflect.
Gain has arisen for me.
It is inconstant, stressful and subject to change.
They do not discern it as it has come to be.
So that's what's missing.
We presume that once I've got something, it's just going to grow, that it's not going to leave me.
But it's a good thing to be able to remind oneself that whatever I have received, which is bringing me joy, pleasure, etc.,
This too will pass, you know.
So one of the things I one of the things I try to remind people to do is that after lunch, you know, to say to yourself, well, this is one less lunch in this lifetime.
We can we can measure our lives by how many lunches we have, how many breakfasts we have.
And then those people who are not instructed, you see, they welcome, they sort of grab hold of an arisen gain and rebel against an arisen loss.
And so it's the same with status and disgrace, with praise and blame and with pleasure and pain.
As they are thus engaged in welcoming and rebelling,
They are not released from birth, aging and death, from sorrows, lamentations, pain, distresses and despairs.
They are not released, I tell you, from suffering and unhappiness.
And of course, those who are awakened, those who have developed to some degree, then, of course, they don't welcome it in that sense of wanting to indulge it.
They just receive it.
And this is the difference, he says, the distinction.
This is the distinguishing factor between a well-instructed disciple of the noble ones and an uninstructed, run-of-the-mill person.
So what's this underlying attitude that we're trying to develop to all these worldly conditions?
It's equanimity.
Yeah, it's equanimity.
And this comes about
more and more as identity becomes about a self becomes less and less.
The less we personalize things, the more we find ourselves at ease with the way things are.
And it's this sense of self which is producing all the problems.
And we undermine that by reminding ourselves what the correct or should we say,
the more wholesome, skillful attitude ought to be.
And it's, what do they say?
It's a working process.
I wouldn't talk about progress.
See, don't get involved with progress.
Just get involved with process.
How do I, you know, get rid of these wrong attitudes that I have to these eight worldly winds, which are going to happen anyway in my life?
You know, we're not going to stop it.
So it's one of the attractions of the Buddha's teachings that he really is also, you know, buried his teachings as well into daily life.
So it's not just meditation and beautiful mental states and developing metta from the heart.
It's actually driving us into right action, right eightfold path, right speech, right action and right livelihood.
And one of the things we have to do is just be able to handle these eight worldly winds.
Very good.
I hope that these words have been of some assistance.
They have not caused confusion.
And that by your careful investigation of these eight worldly winds, you will soon be liberated from all suffering.
Sooner rather than later.